مستمرين معاكم كمان مشاهدينا في متابعه
تطورات حالات التسمم اللي بتصيب الطيبات
الايرانيات في المدارس والجامعات واليوم
بعد يوم بنسمع زياده فيها الطالبات صاروا
الاف والمدارس والجامعات صاروا بالمئات
واللي بيصير انه الطالبات في الحرم
المدرسي او الجامعي بيستنشقوا غاز محد لسه
عارف ايش هو ولا من فين مصدره وبتظهر
عليهم اعراض تسمم وبيتنقلوا للمستشفيات
وبعد تجاهل وانكار لفتره شفنا امس
القيادات الايرانيه بتعترف بالازمه وبتفتح
تحقيق وقال يعني بتقول لازم نعاقب
المتورطين بس في نفس الوقت شايفينها
مؤامره ضد البلد
[تصفيق]
السلطات لا قالت مين هدول اللي اعتقلتهم
ولا ايش علاقتهم في الموضوع ولا اي تفاصيل
لكن الداخليه كانت اصدرت بيان كمان قالت
فيه انه تحقيقاتها للان توصلت لانه في 250
فصل في انحاء البلاد تعرضوا للهجمات من
الطالبات التي تاثروا عددهم محدود مدري
يعني كانوا يبغوا العدد كم يعني يكون
علشان يحسبوها ويحسبوها كارثه يعني على
العموم البيان او بيان الداخليه قال كمان
انه فحصوا عينات من المتضررات وتبين انه
ما في مواد سامه او خطيره وانه اقل من 5%
طلعت عليهم اصلا اعراض اما 9% من الطالبات
اللي نقلوا او 90% عفوا من الطالبات اللي
نقلوا للمستشفيات ما كانوا من اللي تسمموا
لا كانوا من الطالبات اللي اثرت عليهم
الحادثه نفسيا يعني شافت زميلتها او
رفيقتها متسممه فتاثرت وخافت على نفسها
طيب لسه ما خلصت النتائج طولوا بالكم
معايا نتابع البيع لانه البيان وقال انه
اللي صار عمل اجرامي متعمد ومستمرين في
البحث في هذا المجال اما النتيجه اللي انا
ما اعرف ايش قصدهم فيها فقالوا فيها انه
بعض الحالات اللي تسببت في التهابات ناتجه
عن اعمال المغامره وما شرحوا ولا وضحوا
ايش يعني اعمال المغامره طيب اذا كان بيان
وزاره الداخليه وزاره الصحه هي كمان كان
لها تصريحات انه ترى 10% بس من الطالبات
عانوا اعراض حقيقيه والباقيين كله توتر
وقلق وقالوا انه المواد المستخدمه في
الهجمات هي مواد متاحه وعلى فكره السلطات
الايرانيه لها كم يوم بتسمي المواد هذه
اللي تعرضت لها الطالبات منشطات لغسام ولا
مواد خطيره ولا شيء لا لا هذه منشطات بحسب
كلامهم طيب عموما الاحتجاجات مكمله في
الشوارع والناس بتطالب تفهم ايش اللي جالس
بيصير
[موسيقى]
البيت الابيض تدخل امس وطلعت السكرتيره
الاعلاميه كريم جون بيير وقالت انه راح
يكون في تفويض للبعث الدوليه المستقله
لتقصي الحقائق في ايران للتحقق في الموضوع
[موسيقى]